هذا موجز الاخبار من قناه الجزيره اقتحمت
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه باحات المسجد
الاقصى للمره الثانيه خلال 24 ساعه واعتدت
على المصلين قبل انتهاء صلاه التراويح
مساء اطلقت قوه الاحتلال الرصاصه المطاطي
على المصلين والمعتكفين واجبرتهم على
الاخلاء
[تصفيق]
هذا واقتحمت مجموعات من المستوطنين باحات
الاقصى مجددا صباح اليوم تحت حمايه مشدده
من قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
يعقد مجلس الامن الدوليه اليوم جلسه
مشاورات مغلقه بشان التطورات في المسجد
الاقصى بناء على طلب فلسطيني اردني وعشيت
الجلسه قال المتحدث باسم الامين العام
للامم المتحده صفا ذو شريكا انطونيو يشعر
بالصدمه والفزع من صور العنف التي او الذي
مارسته القوات الاسرائيليه على المصلين في
المسجد القبلي بالمسجد الاقصى
التقى وزير الخارجيه السعودي فيصل بن
فرحان مع نظيره الايراني حسين امير
عبداللهيان في العاصمه الصينيه حسب
الخارجيه الايرانيه فان اللقاء يبحث ملفات
اعاده العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين الجانبين
والاجراءات العمليه لفتح السفرتين
والممثليات الدبلوماسيه وكان البلدان قد
اتفقه على تطبيع العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
واعاده فتح السفارات في اتفاق تم بواسطه
صينيه
قال الرئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهاني ان استكمال العمليه
السياسيه يجري الان بالسرعه المطلوبه على
نحو يفسد الابواب على كل محاولات الرد على
حد تعبيره واضاف البرهان في بيان بمناسبه
ذكرى انتفاضه ابريل
1985 ان تاجيل التوقيعي على الاتفاق
السياسي تم لوضع الاطر المتينه التي تحافظ
على زخم الثوره وعنفوانها واوضح رئيس مجلس
السياده السوداني ان الاطراف المعنيه تعمل
الان بجد لاكمال النقاش حول الموضوعات
المتبقيه
استقبل رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي كيفن
مكرتي في كاليفورنيا رئيسه تايوان وقال ان
صداقه بلاده مع الشعب التايواني اقوى من
اي وقت مضى وانه متفائل بشان ايجاد سبل
للعمل المشترك لتعزيز الديمقراطيه
والسلامه ودعا الى مواصله بيع الاسلحه
بين رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي ورئيسه
تايوان في كاليفورنيا وقالت انه انتهاك
لمبدا صين واحده في غضون ذلك قال وزير
الدفاع التايواني ان هناك حامله طائرات
صينيه تتمركز حاليا على بعد 200 البحري
قباله الساحل الشرقي لتايوان وكانت بيجين
اعلنت مشاركه اول سفينه صينيه كبيره في
تدريبات عسكريه
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]